So, it's $70
a day to rent a car.
Totally doable.
Do you wanna
insure the driver?
Yes.
Do you want to insure
against other cars?
Yes.
Potholes?
Weather?
Yes
Yes.
Trees?
Uh-huh.
God?
Yeah.
Transition insurance for when I
pull the car around-- make sure
you get that last
one--I'm a terrible driver.
Okay.
Sure.
With all that,
it comes to $125.
Okay.
License and credit
card, please.
Oh.
You're under 25.
That changes
things.
That'll be $1,100.
Oh... we're gonna need
one moment, please.
Thank you so much.
All right,
come 'ere, huddle up.
Okay, so, we both know that I'm
25, but what Mary doesn't yet
know is that my
license is expired.
We're gonna need to come up with
a plan in the next 20 seconds
inside this huddle, 'cause
when I created the huddle,
I thought by this
time I'd have a plan.
I don't.
I'm gonna keep--
Here's my license and the AMEX
should cover
insurance.
This isn't a
sugar daddy thing.
This is just an old, established
"guy paying for his younger
friend he has sex
with" kind of thing,
so just get that right out
of your mind, you know?
(woman)
Well, you're
all set.
There's only
one vehicle left.
It doesn't have AC,
but it's really spacious.
We'll take it.
(brakes squeal)
Oh...okay.
Gotta love that
transitions insurance.